we start today with Donald Trump's CNN
Town Hall we are going to talk about how
CNN handled it we will talk about
reaction to the town hall from Trump
supporters we will talk about reaction
to the town hall from Republicans and
Democrats in elected office and from
other networks but we have to start with
the town hall itself which was two hours
of trump lying uncontrollably calling
the host Caitlin Collins nasty and
telling the same corrosive Greatest Hits
detrimental to American democracy that
we have seen him tell for years now with
some pushback from Caitlin Collins but a
structure that was completely unprepared
for the absurdity and Insanity of the
event at the very top level MSNBC put
together this sort of highlight uh list
which included Trump continuing to say
say he really won 2020. saying that e
Gene Carroll made up a fake story and is
a whack job remember a jury found that
Trump sexually assaulted her uh called
the moderator Caitlyn Collins a nasty
person complimented Vladimir Putin
refused to side with Ukraine in that
invasion of Ukraine by Russia defended
keeping classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago pushed Republicans to default
on the U.S debt and said he was inclined
to Pardon a bunch of the January 6th
rioters we're talking about criminals
let's get right into it because it there
is just so I can't cover even everything
that was lied about because there were
so many lies but let's start Trump found
liable of sexual assault the day before
and then the next day gets a prime time
it might have been a one hour now I
don't remember if it was one or two
hours I watched it in an accelerated
format after the fact standing ovations
from a sycophant audience and Trump
arguably admitting to criminality during
this event Trump asked those classified
documents did you show them to anyone
and Trump says not really which I think
means yes he did when it comes to your
documents did you ever show those
classified documents to anyone not
really I would have the right to by the
way they would Declassified after not
that I can think of let me just tell you
I have the absolute right to do whatever
I want with them now understand not
really isn't no and immediately saying
not really but I could definitely do it
if I wanted to sounds like he is saying
yes another one of the most notable
moments was when he called Caitlin
Collins a nasty person now when I do my
analysis of how this was handled you can
simultaneously realize Caitlyn Collins
tried to do a good job and when she
pressed Trump he insulted her but also
the way that this was generally handled
by CNN was a disaster this is sort of
the epitome of that when she actually
tries to press Trump he just insults her
why you held on to those documents when
you knew the federal government was
seeking them and then had given you a
subpoena to return are you ready are you
ready can I talk yeah what's your answer
can I do you mind I would like for you
to answer the question okay it's very
simple to answer that's why I asked it
it's very simple that you're a nasty
person I'll tell you
and of course the sycophant crowd cheers
attack think about this this event
embodies the downfall of Journalism but
in more than one way
it's the downfall of Journalism in that
CNN was in way over its head and
completely unprepared structurally to
handle the uncontrollable lies flowing
out of Trump's mouth like projectile
vomiting they were unprepared to do that
that's a problem right in journalism but
also it's the continued attacks on
journalism where when you attack the
moderator who's doing their job or
trying to
your supporters cheer we Trump's
insulting the person asking questions
really sad on many many levels the
topics came up related to the 2020
election and Caitlyn Collins again she's
trying tries to confront Trump with the
reality that the things he's saying even
Republicans say aren't true about the
2020 election and he just steamrolls
right past never had a pay before we
nobody can afford to continue to pay
what's happening with energy but we were
energy independent we were getting out
of Afghanistan with strength and with
dignity and instead we got out we looked
like fools probably the most
embarrassing moment in the history of
our country we have a lot of questions
about the economy and foreign policy
tonight but but what you just said there
Republican officials debunked those
claims about fraudulent ballots we want
to give you a chance tonight who
Republican officials in Georgia and
every single state there is no your own
election officials Mr President so we
wanted to be afraid to take on the issue
but we have a big problem in this
country we have
we have elections that were horrible if
you look at what happened in
Pennsylvania Philadelphia if you look at
what happened in Detroit Michigan this
is all debunked lies understand that if
you look at what happened in Atlanta
millions of votes and all you have to do
is take a look at government cameras
you'll see them people going to 28
different voting booths to vote to put
in seven ballots a piece
that none of that happened because
because there is no evidence that your
own election officials testified to and
have said that Republicans in these
states did this in Georgia there were
multiple recounts including a hand
recount we have questions about the
claims that you're making tonight from
voters on this topic I want to bring in
Scott Dustin from Concord he works in
all right and then this guy we're not
going to play it but this guy then asked
if Trump is going to stop all of this
stuff about 2020 and Trump basically
responded well if there's no more fraud
then I'll stop talking about them the
topic of documents did come back up
Donald Trump claimed Obama took
documents as well and Caitlin Collins
says Obama did not take documents jack
is not criminal I took the documents I'm
allowed to you know who else took them
Obama took them Nixon took them
oh he didn't the difference the
difference
[Applause]
more than anybody is Joe Biden he has
1800 boxes
[Applause]
and nobody talks about him now these are
all lies and again Caitlyn Collins is
trying Trump is totally steamrolling her
in absolutely every way here they then
uh bring up the Insurrection the riots
January 6 2021 Trump says Nancy Pelosi
is to blame Caitlin Collins tries to
interject about Trump's continued lies
about 10 000 National Guard troops
soldiers Etc and Trump just keeps going
and going and going
oh boy
looks like we have a bit of a glitch
here with this clip but let's see if we
can fix it for everybody here we go we
can go sentence after sentence after
sentence of things I said and things I
put out one of the big problems was that
Nancy Pelosi crazy Nancy is a
affectionately call her crazy Nancy
Pelosi and the mayor of Washington were
in charge as you know of security and
they did not do the adjustment
well I offered them National Guard I
said we'll give you soldiers we'll give
you a National Guard Trump did not offer
Trump asked for soldiers to protect him
that's the incredible thing it's an it's
an unbelievable
complete rewriting of History blaming
people whose responsibility is not what
Trump claims is their responsibility and
then we find out Trump was worried about
his own safety he wanted soldiers there
to protect him give you whatever you
want and they turned me down
excuse me she turned me down in writing
they turned me down but you're acting
secretary Chris Miller at the time he
says you never gave
a full order to to deploy the National
Guard but when it came to that day just
the opposite Miller wrote a book and
he's a fantastic guy and he was ready to
go they turned him down if you these are
all lies and then maybe one of the most
horrifying aspects to this and again
with a sycophant crowd like this if the
crowd's cheering that's a moment you
want to zoom in on because Trump's
probably saying something horrible and
indeed Donald Trump says he will pardon
a large number of the alleged
insurrectionists and convicted
insurrectionists and what they've done
and I love that question because what
they've done to so many people is
nothing nothing and then what they've
done to these people they've persecuted
these people and yeah my my answer is I
am most likely if I get in I will most
likely I would say it will be a large
portion of them you know
they did a very
if the crowd's cheering it's probably a
really bad moment and that alone Trump's
saying I am going to mass pardon
criminals who were rioting on my behalf
put everything else aside put the rest
of the Town Hall put everything aside
that alone is a great reason not to vote
for Donald Trump when Caitlin Collins
brings up Mike Pence Mike Pence trumps
former Vice President says Trump
endangered my life that day with what he
did and what he incited uh will you
apologize and Trump says Ah I don't
really think I I didn't heeded some
Pence did something wrong by not holding
up the certification of Joe Biden but
one person who was at the Capitol that
day as you know was your vice president
Mike Pence who says that you endangered
his life on that day I don't think he
was in any danger Mr President do you
feel that you owe him an apology no
because he did something wrong he should
have put the votes back to the state
legislatures and I think we would have
had a different outcome I really do
crowd's cheering when the crowd cheered
it was a signal that this is one of the
crazier things that Donald Trump is
saying of course Mike Pence did not have
the authority or ability or right or
permission call whatever you want he did
not have the ability to reject the
election of Joe Biden and to somehow try
to stuff Trump into the Oval Office for
four more years then the topic of e Gene
Carroll came up now I want you to
remember that the day before this town
hall a jury found Trump liable civilly
for the sexual assault and defamation of
e Gene Carroll for Trump's assault on
her in the 1990s in a Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in Manhattan Trump
brings up that e Gene Carroll had a pet
named vagina and that the judge wouldn't
let that be part of the trial
I'm not kidding folks it's 20 23. former
president running again this is what
he's talking about hey dog
or her cat was named vagina the judge
wouldn't allowed to put that in all of
these things he but with her they could
put in anything Access Hollywood jury of
nine people who found you liable of
sexual abuse do you think that that will
deter women from voting for you no I
don't think so because I think the whole
thing
just so you understand ready
I never met this woman I never saw this
woman he never saw her I I don't believe
a word he's saying and then Trump
actually goes into a detailed story
about the circumstances I think I just
lost the light in my studio that was
weird uh goes into a detailed we'll get
that fixed up
he tells a story about what's being said
happened and it's one of the most
bizarre moments of the entire thing I
never met this woman I never saw this
woman this woman said I met her at the
front door of Bergdorf Goodwin which I
rarely go into other than for a couple
of charities
I met her in the front door she was
about 60 years old and this is like 22
23 years ago she was 52. I met her in
the front door at Bergdorf Goodman I was
immediately attracted to her she was
immediately attracted to me and we
had this great chemistry we're walking
into a crowded department so we had this
great chemistry and a few minutes later
we end up in a a room a dressing room a
burgdorf Goodman right near the kitchen
the crowd laughs and laughs and laughs
they just love it remember Trump's been
found civilly liable for sexual assault
and they're just making fun of the
victim the crowd's loving it everybody's
having a party register
and then she found out there were locks
in the door so she said I found one that
was open she found one she learned this
at trial she found one that was open
what kind of a woman meets somebody and
brings them up and within minutes you're
playing hanky-panky in a dressing room
okay I don't know if she was married
then or not John Johnson I feel sorry
for you John Mr President can I so think
of it an entire crowd on national TV led
by Trump disgustingly laughing about the
sexual assault that remember it's not a
mere allegation now a jury found Trump
liable for that and the crowd just
having a grand old time Caitlin Collins
did ask Trump about the infamous Access
Hollywood tape where Trump says you can
just grab women by the you know what uh
Trump uh Trump defends it says there's
nothing wrong because he says they let
you do it they let you do it there was a
tape deposition of you from October in
it you defended the comments that you
made on that excess Hollywood tape about
being able to grab women how you want do
you stand by those comments I said if
you you're famous and rich or whatever I
said but I said of your star
you are and I said women let you I
didn't say you grab I said women let you
know you didn't use that word but if you
look women let you now they said will
you take that back I said look
for a million years this is the way it's
been
I want to be honest this is the way it's
been I can take it back if you'd like to
but if you're a famous person if you're
a star and I'm not referring to myself
I'm saying people that are famous people
that are from the deposition people that
are rich people that are powerful
uh they tend to do pretty well in a lot
of different ways okay and you would
like me to take that back I can't take
it back because it happens to be true I
said it's been true for one million
years million years even before Homo
sapiens it was absolutely the truth
Trump then moving on to what we might
call foreign policy the idea of trump
foreign policy I know it's kind of
laughable but
um given a number of opportunities to
say you know given that Russia invaded
Ukraine and Russia is in the wrong do
you want Ukraine to come out Victorious
from that or do you want Russia to
successfully take over Ukraine Trump
refused to answer that question Nancy
the question here is would you give
Ukraine weapons and funding if you were
I would sit down let me just put it a
nice away uh if I'm president I will
have that War settled in one day 24
hours
how would you settle that war in one day
and again the crowd's cheering so it
must be Trump said something stupid and
indeed how on Earth are you going to
settle that in 24 hours
they both have weaknesses and they both
have strengths and within 24 hours that
war will be settled it'll be over it'll
be absolutely do you want Ukraine to win
this war
uh I don't think in terms of winning and
losing I think in terms of getting it
settled so we stop killing all these
people and breaking them oh sounds like
a sort of both sides perspective on
something Russia did here
and the crowd loves it
yeah
follow up on that because that's a
really important excuse me
can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this war
I want everybody to stop dying they're
dying Russians and ukrainians who are
dying like dogs so he refused to answer
that refused to answer that and then
lastly and not surprisingly the cherry
on top Trump refuses to commit to
accepting the results of the 2024
election for you you're are running in
the 2024 race if you are the Republican
nominee and you are in that 2024 race
will you commit tonight to accepting the
results of the 2024 election yeah if I
think it's an honest election absolutely
that means no to accepting the results
of the election regardless of the
outcome the woman answer it again if I
think it's an honest election I would be
honored to and right now we are so far
ahead of both Democrat and Republican
and you know what if I don't win this
country is going to be in big trouble
it's so sad to see what's happening but
no commitment
it's an honest election correct okay so
not committing to accepting the 2020 or
our election results and Trump just kind
of waves off Caitlin Collins and the
crowd laughs and everybody has a grand
old time this is dangerous everybody's
laughing off the fact that he did it in
2020 and he's saying he's going to do it
again in 2024 if he loses he will say
that it was rigged
disastrous event for democracy let's now
talk about CNN's role in this I said I
was keeping an open mind let's see how
CNN handles the Trump Town Hall maybe
they will hold Trump accountable maybe
it will be produced in a way that Trump
can't steamroll Caitlyn Collins and tell
lies with a sycophant crowd and
everybody's going to cheer and you know
it won't just be Caitlyn Collins meekly
every once in a while trying to fact
check but unfortunately that's basically
what it was and we can simultaneously
say
Caitlin Collins offered some token
resistance she did try to do some fact
checking sometimes more successfully
sometimes less successfully in the
context of trump lying uncontrollably
spreading really dangerous corrosive
lies about American democracy in front
of a crowd where when they cheered it
was the absolute worst stuff the worst
of making fun of sexual assault victim e
Gene Carroll uh attacking Caitlyn
Collins is nasty when the crowd cheered
or laughed you knew Trump was doing the
absolute worst stuff and so Caitlin
Collins tried but she couldn't even
remotely control Trump in her defense
very few people could and that's where
we have to question what was the reason
for doing this town hall
it's May of the year before the election
there isn't even really a serious
Challenger to Trump yet I know DeSantis
is in the 20s DeSantis isn't running
right now Nikki Haley has no shot Vivek
ramaswami has no shot so why do a town
hall like this in May of 2023 for the
ratings it's that simple Chris slicked
taking over CNN and saying this is what
we're going to do Trump ignored the
token fact checks he spoke over Caitlin
Collins the crowd cheer there was no way
to control it when you zoom out I don't
see how America was served by this event
I don't see how voters were served and
the way I'd characterize it in some
total is Caitlyn Collins did the best
job she could by herself
on stage in front of a crowd of trump
sycophants but the situation made it an
impossibility it was doomed to fail and
after the break will look at the
reaction from uh some in the media and
some in elected office
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right was the Trump CNN Town Hall
the most corrosive television event in
political history depends who you ask
for example a republican Congressman
Byron Donalds was actually
reinvigorated into continuing to not
answer the simple question did Trump win
in 2020 or did he lose Trump setting the
tone during the town hall that he's
insisting he won Byron Donald's asked
about it he will not acknowledge nearly
three years later that Trump simply lost
that day this is one of the reasons why
these events are so corrosive listen to
this
can I what are the facts you do
acknowledge Donald Trump lost the 2020
election correct again we're going to
continue to talk about 22.
let me tell you
we're frankly kind of tired of y'all
bringing this up inflation border you
don't have the courage to express your
Americans
I'm a republican voter voters want to
talk about inflation the Border fentanyl
the debt ceiling foreign policy if you
want to talk about the 2020 election
let's talk about this we do know that
Mark Elias was in many jurisdictions
suing to actually change election
procedures which by the way is at the
hands of the state legislature in every
state according to the Constitution not
in the hands of Courts not in the hands
of the Supreme Court the state
legislature we do know that to be a fact
we do know that true you won't State
your opinion about actually actually
what happened in the 2020. you guys want
me to make a state and this is like
Frank let me tell you right now this is
not a trick question they act like it's
a trick question it's just okay fine you
want Trump to have won you want him to
win in 2024 you think Biden's bad but
can we just start with Biden did win can
we start there they refuse Joe
Scarborough from MSNBC this this morning
had actually a pretty good take about
the impact of this town hall
no surprises and yet
it was just it was a disgraceful
performance yes
um I'm constantly telling people not to
catastrophize over Trump that he's
actually going to lose there's a former
Republican member of Congress by the way
because he keeps drilling down deeper
and deeper into his base
um
but it is it is uh I I can't believe I'm
I'm going to use
catastrophizing language here uh but it
was it was just it was disgraceful on
every level yeah
it showed uh I won't I wouldn't say it's
dangerous for democracy because we
passed that a long time ago
but it showed the corrosive effects of
trumpism over eight years
and I've got to say
I I the most shocking part was an
audience
who cheered on a president who tried to
overturn
American democracy yeah Joe Scarborough
is completely right now a practical
question becomes did Trump convince
anybody one way or the other uh we'll
get to Van Jones's take on what it did
to Democrats but they actually had a
focus group on CNN with a group of trump
supporters and you may or may not be
interested to hear that it didn't affect
any of them one way or the other Trump's
spending that time just lying and lying
and lying it just had no impact one way
or the other vote but that's what they
have in common that most of them are
Trump supporters what I want to ask you
first of all is do you think show of
hands anybody think Donald Trump looks
better after this town hall no hands and
if you think he looks worse
No Hands maybe you think the same thing
about him as you did when you walked in
sorry so on Trump supporters it had no
impact whatsoever what about on
Democrats well van Jones says
if you watch this and you're a Democrat
you're probably feeling a lot better
about Joe Biden all of a sudden I think
if if you're a Democrat watching that
you think we've been criticizing and
complaining about Biden
this is a horror show that we don't want
a rerun of and I think a lot of
Democrats were appalled by his behavior
him throwing Ukraine under the bus uh
you know I hope he gets sued again this
morning for libel and and slander and
everything else he's been getting so
horrible uh you know toward the people
who have been on the other side of his
legal cases but you know I think that
we've got to be careful here now because
uh Trump has a particular trick that he
uses with Nostalgia uh the whole make
America great again is about there was
this era that was wonderful it was 1950
which we've talked about before so
listen I I think the best case scenario
as atrocious and disgusting as the event
was uh on the merits the hope is
Trump supporters still support him
other Republicans were maybe appalled
and of course Democrats may be appalled
enough that now they are more interested
in coming out to vote in in 2024 against
Trump if he is indeed the nominee it's
still a while to go but let's hope
that's the outcome let's now go to
George Anthony devolder Santos George
Santos the lying of lying congressman
who was arrested yesterday on 13
criminal counts held a manic unhinged
press conference after being arrested
it's wacky we're going to look at it
it's just really really wacky stuff and
he is trying to do the Trump thing where
he says it's a Witch Hunt and it's all
unfair and blah blah blah blah blah he
gives this event in Islip New York
vishbura is the guy if you're watching
in the blue checkered suit over Santos's
right shoulder he's increasingly a
corrosive actor in Republican politics
there in Long Island
um let's listen to what Santa had to say
and this is this is crazy I'm warning
you this is Bonker stuff
look this is the beginning of the
ability for me to address and defend
myself we have an indictment we have all
we have the information that the
government wants to come after me on and
I'm going to comply I've been comply
throughout this entire process I have no
desire not to comply at this point
they've been gracious in there now I'm
gonna have to go and fight to defend
myself the reality is is I'm sorry it's
a Witch Hunt because
it makes no sense that in four months
four months five months I'm indicted you
have Joe Biden's entire family receiving
deposits from nine the crowd not
reacting positively to that nine family
members receiving money from foreign
from foreign destinations into their
bank accounts it's been years of
exposing a lot of you here have reported
on them and yet no investigation is
launched into them I'm gonna fight I
will and I'm just going I'm getting back
there I'm gonna fight my battle I'm
gonna deliver all right so it's a Witch
Hunt he says asked whether he will
resign he says that he will not
will not resign now he may be kicked out
one interesting thing that happened in
the last 24 hours is that Kevin McCarthy
the Republican Speaker of the House said
I do not support the re-election of
George Santos now you might say who
cares if Kevin McCarthy doesn't support
it in general
Republican leadership supports the
re-election of Republicans who are
running for re-election so this could be
the beginning of Republicans actually
saying uh we've got to
um we've got to do something about this
hilariously he was he George Santos was
asked why did you apply for unemployment
benefits When you were making 120 Grand
a year working and of course this is one
of the different frauds that he's
alleged to have committed and he says
well that this is all going to be part
of my defense in an orderly fashion and
we'll start right here
why would you apply for unemployment
benefits When you had a job making a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year right by the way I have for people
who are watching there's about 80 of who
are not watching there's about 80
microphones in front of him it almost
look satirical
and there's a guy in the back holding a
sign that says devolder defrauds
devoters which is just a beautiful dish
it's this SNL can't do anything with
this because it wouldn't look any
different to parody this event this is
part of my defense accurate information
and I will get to clear my name on this
during the pandemic it wasn't very clear
I don't understand where the
government's getting their information
but I will present myself
in unemployment benefits sir how is that
acceptable ma'am like I said my
employment was changed during the time I
don't understand where the government's
coming from I'll present my defense he's
all totally confused at another moment
he completely delusionally says that in
a couple of years he'll be chairman of a
committee in the house now listen he may
or may not make it out of the next month
I don't know it depends on what
Republicans are going to do the idea
that he's going to get reelected and
subsequently become the chair of a
committee really is a level of delusion
that raises a lot of red flags
well look the way I look at it I'll be a
chairman of a committee in a couple of
years if you just look at the standards
of Congress look at the signage there
you go soon this is no worse than
anything everybody else is doing in the
House and Senate so he'll be chairman of
a committee trying to put sort of a
positive spin on this entire thing he
says he's feeling fine despite 13
criminal charges please
I'm addressing one of your colleagues
here I don't want to give the back of
the camera so
as usual Jody I I do my best to be a
positive person life is already as bad
as it gets out there so I I'm fine and
somebody yelling his lips are moving
therefore he must be lying is the
implication
um okay he this is maybe the funniest
moment he starts talking about getting
back to Washington DC to vote on it like
a border Bill he's pretending to be a
normal congressman and there's something
so funny like yes members of Congress
vote on bills but the idea that this guy
is going to now be able to just pretend
to be a normal Congressman with 13
criminal counts against him as a joke
uh what are those consequential votes in
in this Congress which is a border Bill
and I'm very looking forward to being
their devote honor all right he's going
to pretend to be a normal congressman
and then lastly
um Fox News caught up with uh desantos
with Santos's lawyer on the way out the
lawyer was mostly interested in finding
his car but he did say
I don't really have anything to do with
Santos choosing to hold that wacky press
conference you didn't have too much that
you wanted to share at this time you
know he climbed his feeling
awesome let me just find my dog it's
looking for his car but hold on with us
Martha
I mean he had a lot to say in that press
conference that's up to him okay I know
you said you didn't want to try it in
the media but how is he feeling he
looked a little nervous when he was in
court today a lot of serious allegations
how many times have you been arrested
all right so making the point that
people just get nervous when they get
arrested but that it's really up to
Santos whether he holds these press
conferences so a completely manic wacky
event it's taking on a sort of circus
Sideshow feel and it seems as though
Santos can't get away from circus side
shows we're going to see it we'll see if
this guy survives the next month I hope
he doesn't but I don't have a prediction
right now
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with Matt
Desmond who's a professor of Sociology
at Princeton University and also author
of the book poverty by America really
appreciate your time today uh looking
forward to this conversation me too
thanks for having me so when we talk
about poverty in the United States we
know that on average and we can Define
average a few different ways the United
States is a very very rich country we've
all heard you know you put Bill Gates in
a room with poor people the mean net
worth gets very high but it doesn't
really represent the situation for
everybody other than Bill Gates in that
room is it a mathematical reality that
even though there are very rich people
in the United States and that sort of
skews these averages poverty is still
very high do we need to go beyond that
to really understand the source of it
the United States stands alone is the
richest country in the world with the
worst poverty so our child poverty rate
is double that of other peer Nations
like Canada South Korea Germany Angus
Deaton The Economist estimated that over
5 million Americans live in abject
poverty by global standards getting by
on four dollars a day or less and look
one in three of us live in homes making
fifty five thousand dollars or less a
lot of those homes aren't considered
officially poor but what else do you
call trying to raise two kids on 55k in
Boston so there's a giant amount of
insecurity and poverty in this Richland
when we think about poverty part of what
we have to talk about is how we're
measuring it and as you're talking about
there are people who by the definition
in the United States aren't poor but
that the Practical day-to-day realities
certainly mirror poverty as we
understand it can you talk a little bit
about how the definition of poverty in
the United States has changed over time
so there's a lot of different ways to
measure poverty researchers do not agree
on what the best measure is you know for
me one way to measure hardship is just
to measure hardship and so you can look
at something like evictions they're up
20 since 2000. look at the share of
families visiting food pantries up 19
since 2000 the number of our homeless
school kids is up 74 since the Great
Recession there's a lot of incredibly
troubling signs that poverty is not only
persistent in America but growing you
know the poverty line is a is a pretty
flawed measure but it also tracks pretty
well with those hardship measures the
government introduced another measure
called the supplemental poverty rate
yeah supplemental poverty measure in
2011 and it counted for a lot of kind of
government programs the official poverty
measure ignores but it also counted for
like housing costs and Regional
variation and cost of living which the
official poverty measure also ignores
and when they release that line that new
poverty line the country officially
gained three million more poor people
actually because any reductions in
poverty offset by counting Aid were more
than kind of canceled out by counting
Rising housing and medical costs
I want to really delve into one of the
aspects you write about in the book that
goes above and beyond defining some of
these terms establishing what the
situation currently is and what it has
been and you talk about how affluent
Americans knowingly or unknowingly uh
contribute to poor people remaining poor
and this may be a difficult thing for
for some people to hear and and to
understand can can you talk a little bit
about that and how you lay out the case
for The Knowing or the unknowing aspect
of that
I ran across this line by the novelist
Tommy Orange
um and it goes like this these kids are
jumping out of the windows of burning
buildings falling to their deaths
and we think that the problem is that
they're jumping
and when I read that sentence I was like
man that sounds like the American
poverty debate you know for for hundreds
of years really
our Focus has been on the poor on the
poor themselves
the jumpers you know we should have been
focusing on the fire Who lit it who's
warming their hands by it and many of us
when we have that kind of conversation
and we want to talk about the guy that's
just a little richer than us or a lot
richer than us but the book is really
trying to get a lot of us and by us I
mean those of us that have found some
security and privilege in this country
to really yeah looking hard in our lives
and realize how we're connected to the
problem and the solution a lot of us
consume the cheap Goods the Working Poor
produce a lot of us are invested in the
stock market don't we benefit when our
savings go up even if that savings comes
at a human sacrifice many of us benefit
from tax breaks
and we don't think of those as welfare
programs but they are they cost the
government money and they put money in
our pocket and you know uh a lot of us
hold on to those tax breaks which starve
anti-poverty spending and then we have
the audacity to ask how can we afford to
do more as a country so I think that
when you start looking at the poverty
Problem by looking at the fire you kind
of realize there's so much poverty in
America not in spite of our wealth but
because of it and I think that opens up
new possibilities for change I'm
interested in your thoughts about to
what degree there is Moral Moral
responsibility at the individual
decision level maybe this is analogous
too you know I've talked with my
audience before uh about how if you
think taxes should be higher uh sending
the IRS more money isn't really policy
it's not a solution to the problem it's
not how we got here and so you can
simultaneously
pay I think pay what you legally owe
while advocating that large swaths of
people maybe including yourself should
be paying more if we apply that to the
conversation that we're having about
poverty how should the individual look
at their level of responsibility here
I think we should commit ourselves
becoming poverty abolitionists you know
we should view poverty not as a
unfortunate aspect of American life but
as an abomination
and I think like other abolitionist
movements to move into abolish slavery
the prison you know we should recognize
that profiting from someone else's pain
corrupts all of us
and so that's a that's a political
project that's going to take renewed
political movements and policies but it
also is a personal project and that
requires us to shop differently invest
differently thinking about taxes you
know for those of us that benefit from
this lopsided welfare state the fact
that the country does so much more to
guard fortunes than to fight poverty
maybe we start a letter writing campaign
we write our Congress person saying like
let's wind down these things I don't
need this this is also a neighbor to
neighbor conversation over the fence
line conversation not because you know
these little kind of personal moves will
abolish poverty but those personal moves
multiplied over and over again builds a
political will that empowers our
lawmakers to act one of the areas that's
a topic of much much discussion with
lawmakers and in communities and with
neighbors is about zoning practices
approval boards for condos restricted
income condos all these different things
can we talk a little bit about that in
the sense of you know we we know about
the long history of exclusionary zoning
practices practices in lending many of
us have talked about those realities we
now sometimes see I mean recently in
Brooklyn I was talking with some friends
about a project that was putting in I
think it was a dozen or so units and the
idea is we're going to sell the Dozen
units to six buyers and these are going
to be income limited so everybody buys
two units you live in one we create
lower income landlords it all sounds
interesting but is it really going to
are we really going to deal with this
problem
piecemeal in that way or does the
solution really have to come from higher
and be broader and bigger
yeah I think both and everything all the
above you know and I think that
segregation continues to be a driving
force of poverty in America there's
probably no more soulless phrase in the
English language than Municipal zoning
ordinance you know but like that's a
really good way to look at the soul of a
community you know on 75 percent of our
land you can only build a single
detached family home you know we build
these walls around our community and we
hoard affluence behind those walls and
that not only concentrates wealth but it
concentrates poverty outside of our
walls so we have to tear down the Walls
we have to start reaching for broader
inclusive communities which really means
you know going down to your zoning board
meeting at Tuesday night and standing up
and saying look I refuse to deny kids
opportunities my kids get living in this
place we got to build this thing I
refuse to be a segregationist so again
here's a conversation that sounds very
like policy and Abstract yeah but it's
also very personal you know it's about
how we vote how we move the
conversations we're having with our
workers at the water cooler you know and
studies show that you know Democrats are
more likely to embrace affordable
housing than abstract but are no more
likely than conservatives to vote Yes in
their own backyards you know studies
show that conservative renters were
actually more likely to vote Yes on an
affordable housing project than liberal
homeowners so I think our values cannot
stop where our property line begins we
really have to live out these values in
our own lives how do those values apply
or connect to just to pick something
that's often discussed to get your take
on it something like mobile phones and
in in particular in the context of
activism most of us have heard that and
are aware that mobile phones are
connected to so-called conflict minerals
typically from other countries we're now
talking outside the U.S even though
companies like apple and others will say
no everything's fine we're ensuring this
that the other thing isn't going on
videos have surfaced where we see that
there are very young young looking
people hard to say they aren't kids
digging by hand Etc then they're
manufactured they're sold in places like
you know a T-Mobile store Apple Store in
the United States right and we can look
at the wages that are paid there and
they're not astronomic chemically high
but they're sort of like okay and a lot
of these are creating local jobs Etc in
the United States how do we take that
Panorama total and combine it with the
fact that many people who want to be
activists for exactly the issues you're
talking about use the devices to to that
end right so it also plays a role in
their activism how do we unwind
something so seemingly seemingly
complicated when we apply the sort of
standard and critique you're applying
yeah I would love us to apply that kind
of critique to Poverty abolitionism you
know many of us know uh not to eat
chocolate from certain brands because of
these things or we are aware of the
climate consequences of certain
purchases or flights or certain meals
but you know we know that our our
cucumbers it's local organic we don't
know how much the farm hand-picked it we
know where to get our coffee if we want
to Signal certain political values but
we don't ask how much the workers are
getting paid in there I was in in London
a few weeks ago and I saw these stickers
on stores and they said you know we play
we pay a living wage and I went into a
store and I said what tell me about the
sticker and they're like well you know
the standard is here but you know our
company's decided to bring it up to here
I would love to see that kind of thing
happening in America that consumer push
and process and so there's groups like
Union Plus that say Hey you know you
want a candy bar you want a beer these
are these are union made these aren't
and there's organizations like b-core
that says you know these companies have
really high standards of environmental
and social uh Consciousness they pay
their workers well and so I think that
like shopping and investing a little bit
in solidarity with the poor makes a lot
of sense as you as the cell phone
example relates right a lot of us kind
of feel
you know embroiled in these kind of
morally compromising networks and we
want out of it you know and this is
where kind of argument for poverty
abolition isn't just an argument for the
end of this depravity and scarcity it's
about a Freer country a safer country a
happier country in a country where we
don't worry so much about our kids you
know I was I was in London a couple
weeks ago as well and saw the exact same
stickers and found them interesting
should we be economic nationalists in
this conversation in the sense of
prioritizing for example like with
coffee there's very little coffee grown
in the US I think maybe some in Hawaiian
that's basically it so it's coming from
other parts of the world in having this
conversation should we be economic
nationalists in the sense of focusing on
the metrics that relate to the workers
in the U.S or should we be considering
the farm in Costa Rica or wherever and
then with coffee there's a middle person
that's often involved where sometimes a
lot of that money actually gets sucked
in to what degree should we focus on
within the U.S versus outside of it I
think there is an there is something to
be said by starting here and the reason
is building a political will to abolish
poverty in America and I I mean that for
real you know I think we can and should
end poverty in this land of abundance
getting to that goal I think motivates
further investments in countries that
have far more poverty in the United
States and and could could get us there
but if we can't do it here right in our
own backyard I don't think we have a
chance of doing it abroad so I don't
think we have to choose and I think that
often we have these kind of scarcity
arguments right where we're kind of
setting up this false scarcity narrative
I don't think we have to do it but I
think just pragmatically there is
something to be said about okay let's
tackle poverty right here right now then
let's broaden broaden the aperture last
thing I wanted to ask you about um
particularly in the context of the Comet
coveted stimulus bills the Earned Income
Tax Credit has been a topic of
discussion um I I think generally
speaking it's a good program I like the
higher numbers I think it makes sense in
a lot of ways but it also has
limitations which which you've talked
about certainly it doesn't seem to
address the root causes of poverty and
the reasons people might qualify for an
earned uh Earned Income Tax Credit child
tax credit to to begin with can you talk
a little bit about that treating symptom
versus disease Maybe
right so the Earned Income Tax Credit is
kind of a wage subsidy that our poorest
paid workers many of them parents get
every year it's a big part of the safety
net it's about 61 billion dollars a year
and for a lot of families man it's a
lifesaver you know it is a lifesaver it
lifts millions of families out of
poverty
uh but it doesn't address that problem
that low wage problem do I think the
eitc is a good idea do we need it
absolutely do I think that we need other
things that really cut at the root of
poverty yes so those would be things
like worker power
expanding uh representation on corporate
boards for example for workers yes
finding out ways of making organizing
easy instead of this incredibly hard
slow process that it is now things to
really kind of build up uh wages and
fight worker exploitation and you know
as we're doing that let's definitely
make sure those families have enough to
get by with things like the eitc so
short-term Solutions and long-term
Solutions do you see that Democrats or
Republicans are definitively better on
this issue or is that a lot of political
Framing and posturing when there may not
be as much daylight as some would
believe
no I think Democrats are definitely
better on this issue fair I think on the
ground level there's a lot of Americans
that want this right most Americans want
a higher minimum wage most Americans
think the rich aren't paying their fair
share taxes yes most Democrats and most
Republican voters think poverty now is a
relative unfair circumstances not a
moral failing so I think there's a lot
of us on the ground level neighbor to
love neighbor to neighbor that actually
agree on these basic issues of economic
justice but our electives are polarized
from us and that's a problem that we
need to fix the book is poverty by
America we've been speaking with the
book's author Professor Matt Desmond
sociology department at Princeton
University really appreciate your time
and insights thank you David appreciate
you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
we're not going to spend a ton of time
on this because we've we've just not
have we don't have that much time left
on today's show it's been so packed but
I do encourage folks to check out the
arrest warrant and the indictment of
George Anthony devolder Santos including
the full list of charges there's funny
stuff in it and there's interesting
stuff in it I'm going to put up just the
first page of the arrest warrant I don't
know why I find this so damn funny I
don't know if it's a version of satire
of some kind or if it's just totally
standard
the arrest warrant lists him as George
Anthony devolder Santos AKA in quotes
George Santos
I couldn't stop laughing when I saw this
because it it may well be that this has
nothing to do with the fact that he has
changed his public name over time
without I'm not saying he legally
changed his name just the way he has
publicly stated who he is videos where
he says I'm Anthony devolder and I run a
pro-trump group I'm George Santos I'm
George Anthony and all these different
things this may just be a completely
standard thing that is no bearing on on
that George Anthony devolder Santos AKA
George Santos as if he's been living a
under a false name for some period of
time absolutely love it but more
importantly
the indictment and the arrest warrant
describe the offenses which include wire
fraud money laundering theft of public
monies and false statements and it lists
the specific laws that that he is
accused of having broken and there are a
number of Articles you can look at which
go into more detail it's actually seven
counts of wire fraud
three counts of money laundering one
count of a theft of public funds and
then two counts of lying to the House of
Representatives on financial forms
that's the that's the false statements
element of this as the article says from
MSN wire fraud is the most serious
charge and carries a penalty up to 20
years in prison and as is often the case
in these situations if we get to a
guilty verdict someday or a plea a judge
would decide do you serve concurrently
or consecutively different charges and
as you might know if you get seven years
on four different charges
consecutively that's 28 years if they're
concurrent it's seven years total so
just all of the different details that
we're going to be Mitt Romney was asked
now that George Anthony devolder Santos
has been charged criminally with
multiple charges what should happen
and I love that Mitt Romney doesn't just
say he should resign he says he should
already have resigned and this is
exactly the right answer I actually wish
that there were more Republicans
some of them are going to come around
now and say well he should now resign I
wish more people said what Mitt Romney
says in this short six second clip to
CNN's Manu Raju
he should have resigned a long time ago
he said embarrassment to our party he's
embarrassment to the United States
Congress Okay so
yes he should resign now and actually
Republicans in the house should hold a
vote and they should kick him out but
the right take as Mitt Romney has been
one of the few Republican voices willing
to say this is that he should have been
gone a long time ago he never should
have gotten to this point in time
even in even prior to the actual
indictments these Republicans seem very
scared to just come out and say it or
they don't believe it but good for Mitt
Romney for making that clear we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P so many of you calling in about
the Trump town hall on CNN most of you
were appalled let's listen to a couple
of these voicemails
yeah hi David uh I just have to say
about this Trump thing tonight on CNN
I'm about 38 minutes into it and I'm
having to
pause and walk outside and de-stress
every 10 minutes or so but
thing that CNN did here is the crowd
the crowd is full of sickness right it's
like a last track absolutely I mean you
have Caitlin Collins who I honestly you
know I looked at this tonight and I
heard your you know I listened to your
live stream and I heard you're so
earlier today and I'm thinking of myself
the biggest persons you know that's got
everything on the line it's not Trump
it's Kate and Collins
and she's trying to interview this man
where the crowd is literally a laugh
track from the 1960s I don't
understand why CNN put their own
employee in this position but yeah so
this is this is part of the argument I
made about Caitlyn Collins yo there is
praise and criticism of Caitlyn Collins
but putting her in that position with a
sycophant crowd is part of the friendly
nature in in total with which Trump was
given this opportunity uh let's listen
to another caller about the uh Trump
Town Hall I think this is the Eggman I
watched Trump and Caitlyn Collins on CNN
last night like it was a homework
assignment yeah I watched it like I had
to do it because it was something I
needed to report on my wife was watching
with me she walked out of the room it
upset her so much she can't stand Trump
that much you couldn't even listen
anymore but I forced myself to watch I
can't wait to hear what you have to say
yeah
um the Eggman quite appalled by it and
here's one more caller wangan
hi yeah Dave um
semi-longtime listener about maybe less
than a year um
I watched the Trump or listen to the
Trump town hall and it was pretty within
five minutes of listening I was just
like this is a waste of time I mean I
get why CNN did it I mean but we didn't
learn anything about problems that we
didn't already know that's true but we
learned a lot about the state of trump
sycophants because when you look at when
the crowd laughed and when the crowd
cheered it was at the absolute bottom of
the barrel moments when Trump attacked
his own sexual assault victim during the
event the crowd laughed and cheered when
Trump attacked the moderator uh Caitlyn
Collins the crowd laughed and cheered
when Trump said he actually won in 2020
the crowd cheered the crowd was actually
what was new Trump did his Greatest Hits
and it was truly truly horrible we've
got a great bonus show for for you today
we'll talk about the latest out of the
Supreme Court we're going to talk about
Fox News hit with yet another defamation
lawsuit and we will also talk about uh
Senator representing California Dianne
Feinstein's return to the senate for the
first time since February amid calls for
her to resign we'll discuss the entire
circumstances around her return all on
the bonus show thank your lucky stars
every day you're not Dave pagman you
don't have to be me to listen to the
bonus show or to watch it I'll host it
you watch it sign up at joinpakman.com
otherwise we'll be back tomorrow with a
brand new show
foreign